one of the stars and Ubisoft's
impressive III 2015 lineup is tom
clancy's the division and joining me now
on stage Ryan Bernard from Ubisoft and
we are going to talk about the division
because you guys had a pretty memorable
demo up there yeah I hope so I mean
that's kind of what we were shooting for
so you know it's each year we want to
try to bring more of the gameplay more
kind of pull the rapper bappa back a
little bit further and the last the
previous you know the first year was
about kind of you know making a splash
with the game and then last year was
about the open world what's happening
with the scenario and this year will
really focus on the dark zone and how
player versus player works in the game
and player versus player is sort of you
know some a lot of games have player
versus player and player versus
environment as entirely separate things
but that's not really the case in the
division you guys have sort of mixed it
all around together yeah I think you
know the genre for the game you know
like a lot of games you know are going
open world they want you know player
choice is a big thing that's what I
think the gaming community wants so to
be able to create something unique we
wanted to to have a gameplay space where
it's not a battleground it's not a
multiplayer map it's a space that's
right in the core of the gameplay loop
and the core experience where player
versus player I can happen now you guys
talked about the dark zone for the first
time yes this year and you also sort of
in the intro trailer gave these hints at
the story the you know why these people
are the people who are super good with
guns and prepared for this kind of
situation the you know we always knew
this might happen and then we were
activated kind of thing is that are you
only doing the vague hints at this point
or can you give us a little more on the
sort of campaign setting and who these
people are that you're playing at sure
no we've talked about the background i
mean the the the whole premise for the
division was we wanted a new clancy unit
that was going to be an RPG game that
fit within who be sophs very strong
suite of clancy games yeah so from that
kind of birth this thing of well to be
different the the disaster kind of needs
to have happen
so in our scenario of our game you know
the virus is released the society is
kind of crumbling already and this is a
cleansing unit that's different it's
based in home and it's based as a
response unit so uh huh that's how that
came about and so as a response unit it
seems you know sort of the goal we're
seeing here going to this up into the
dark zone is obviously a big risk so
there's got to be some kind of reward
there and we talked you know sort of
mention like they have dark zone Lutz or
something like that but can you give us
a little more concrete information about
what what kind of resources they're able
to pull out from a risky mission like
this sure absolutely it's i mean the the
Lord behind the dark stone is this is
the this is ground zero for the
infection so what military originally
quarantined a smaller area and tried to
stop the spread of the virus that was
obviously ineffective so they had to
pull back and they left all the best
gear equipment supplies in the dark zone
so the besides missions and scavenging
for for resources for materials for
crafting the best loot the best quality
equipment in the game is inside the dark
zone and when you talk about loot you're
you know you got to be talking about the
players loadout and so we've got
obviously guns grenades but are there
any sort of like gear outfits like
what's the extent of the load out you're
gonna be able to customize so the each
agent has a number of slots and so each
slot can be upgraded with a new go bag
larger inventory better thighs legs
boots lots gloves and this can have
statistics like attached to them so it
can help increase your damage with
weapons increase your health pool you
know RPG type type statistics so that's
why you want this loot in the dark side
and now what a sort of you know that
that RPG type like progression
exploration one of the sort of key
things about that is pushing into areas
and encountering enemies that are too
tough for you that are at you know that
you know it's not just about going
through and killing everything you see
it's about making decisions about when
to engage and we saw that in the demo
here the players a trick we're trying to
avoid you know certain areas because of
these high-level enemies I what's your
sort of approach to like how you pace
out that zone and like where you want to
really push back hard on players to
force them to make a decision like that
well I think it's there isn't really any
walls of like we don't want to block
anyone from exploring but so I would
look at it more of like a kind of a
blend from as the level progresses up
through the dark zone and it's it
becomes very apparent since when you
post or kind of aim on an enemy you can
see the level of the of the challenge
and as soon as you get to a certain
level above your agent you kind of
become very ineffective so the game
pretty much tells you when you need to
either get up your levels through doing
missions or killing NPCs of your level
or enemies so you can take them on in
this your we're actually coming up
against what what's called an elite
enemy so it's pretty common for people
to play a lot of games but their armor
they have higher hip points I have dire
to higher damage output so really
encourages players to play together to
take out elites play together you
multiply the power you can really bring
to bear yeah now sort of we're seeing
more than ever hear you guys sort of
evolving this moving between cover
system like this catching on fire
exactly he's got a he's got to get it
you's a medpac real quick so yeah so the
the division is definitely a cover based
game plan it has a shooting mechanics so
you know utilizing cover moving between
covers flanking enemies is really
important to be successful I now voice
chat obviously sort of really a played a
big role in the demo you showed during
the press conference and obviously if
you're playing on a team it's gonna be
really important but I for players who
don't necessarily voice chat are you
guys building anything any kind of
contextual call-out system or as any way
to communicate non-verbally to
communicate yeah I mean it's a good
question the voice is a very it's a it's
a hot topic in the team I right now we
have a fully emote system that's coming
in so you'll be able to kind of let your
intentions be known when you're not
grouped with someone and then of course
there is the void in group and right now
there's no
plans for any type of quick chat system
yeah but if you but if you got the
emotes then you know sort of things will
start to evolve as players start to
understand like yeah points where you
need to communicate stuff like that
absolutely and and really the biggest
telltale is player action if someone
takes cover you know 10 feet away from
your 15 feet away from you or drops up
the turret it's pretty obvious that you
should get into it's a pretty aggressive
move yes so yeah so is there one more
quick thing about voice chat is there a
sort of area chat so you're not just
talking with your team you're saying
like hey you over there what's up so
right now there's no plans for area void
okay we have big betas coming out on a
real few of you heard of those
announcements so we are very very big on
playing the game looking at feedback the
betas are going to be extremely helpful
and it's something we we could look at
if we decide that that's a direction we
need to go sure yeah beta is very
instructive and certainly could be
helpful now I want to we're now in
combat with another team of human
players is that correct so these we just
actually took out some players that were
rogue flagged so when you go into the
dark sewing you come up against another
player you're neutral so you're neither
hostile nor friendly uh-huh if you
aggress aggress them and engage them you
become what we call flagged robe your
ring turns red your watch turns red and
you actually get a bounty on your head
so other players can take you out for
that experience reward out e plus
whatever loot year carries that you're
going to drop so all the loot inside is
contaminated and in order to basically
buy it to equipment to buy non equipment
you need to extract it so that's what we
see them doing here and starting an
extraction which is 90 seconds of very
intense kind of covering your ass and
it's firing up a flare saying and I
imagine maybe there's a mini-map ping
some other on other teams so they could
come sniffing around so the areas are
known on the map they're also known when
they're gonna when they're active when
someone's trying to extract okay
probably that means that you're trying
to get out something good so there we
refer to them pretty much as watering
holes because
its water ripples that's what they do
that's a very vivid image you know on
the Serengeti was what kind of activity
at a track so it gets pretty crazy at
the extraction areas now i think that i
I just I loved when at the end of the
demo you showed like that next level of
betrayal see mate betraying yes because
that's such because you're sort of that
adds an extra layer of tension but like
what's the I don't know our do you ever
do you worry that that might put in the
mindset of players like oh if I'm just
gonna be a real dick every time and get
out every time yeah it's only gonna be
me or no one it's it's it's a it's a
common question actually and I mean
potentially again where we with this is
we want to start the dark zone with as
few designer placed rules as possible
and players generally kind of develop a
rule set amongst themselves yeah if we
see that you know what this mechanic
just really isn't fun people are you
know that nothing ever happens nobody
extracts there it's too much it's too
chaotic we can make adjustments so this
is where we're starting it was the big
guy you know how does PvP work in your
game well this is how pvp works in the
division and and the great thing about
being online about being iterative is
you can always make adjustment yeah
there's ways to and you know better
incentivize cooperation and stuff like
that and i think i just i really
appreciate sort of showcasing that
backstab moment because it like there's
like the delicious darkness to it and i
think that that's part of the appeal of
the division yes I my favorite comment
that we saw was on reddit someone that's
been following the trailers from year to
year and it's we've had the same group
of agents you know and it's why Ryan
after three years good so if you
followed the story its agents playing
together at the end one of them just
screws all of the other ones and takes
all the loot and then he gets right out
of there it's pretty fun in um so that
the dark zone is you know if you sort
you guys that's an area where PvP as
possible is there also areas where you
can sort of just do a PVE thing early so
so the dark zone is a multiplayer space
so you will you'll definitely see other
players may be engaged in PvP the rest
of New York in the open world is what we
call phased so if you and I are playing
together we're in my and I'm the group
leader we're in my copy of New York and
we won't see random players running by
or messing with our mission or you know
trying to engage us which there's no BVB
outside so it's ok but so it's a phased
private space and then once you move
into the dark zone that's a public space
very cool the dark zone aptly named it's
easy and we got a really good look at it
this year I at e3 now can we talk about
the betas for a second when when are
those coming down the pipe because I
know certainly I am interested in
checking out some kind of dark zone
action nice what are we gonna get to do
that we have a beta coming in December
for those of you who have xbox one and
then shortly after that into the new
year we're gonna be on ps4 and PC so no
matter which platform you want to play
the division on you're gonna be able to
check it out early so betas later this
year and early next year and then you
guys aiming for uh maybe late next year
release no we're actually we're March
eighth of next year is George eat this
man it's three months of full beta so
we'll get we have time to look at the
data to react to really make sure the
game is ready so excellent well thank
you so much for coming on here I'm
talking about this division definitely a
game that continues to garner big
interest at e3 thank you it's been a
pleasure ladies and gentlemen that was
Tom Clancy's the division up next we're
gonna take a look at whatever this
schedule says over there I'm actually
taking it off the stage Lucy James is
going to come on for our next slip slate
of demos and she's going to be seeing a
lot of excellent stuff here at e3 so
please stay tuned we've got more coming
at you